Let’s talk about a
mountain territory
that people are killing
each other over.
It’s called Nagorno-Karabakh.
And the fight’s between Armenia and Azerbaijan.
Soldiers and civilians
are being killed.
So why are they fighting?
How long has it been
going on for?
And why are countries like Turkey involved?
The first shots were
fired in July
before all-out war broke out at the end of September.
It’s been the worst fighting there in 25 years.
But the grievances
go back generations.
At the heart of the
dispute is a region called
Nagorno-Karabakh.
And here it is in a crowded neighbourhood
known as the
South Caucasus.
Nagorno-Karabakh
lies entirely
within Azerbaijan’s
borders.
It’s internationally recognised as being part of the country.
Full stop.
Here’s the thing.
It’s controlled by
ethnic Armenians
backed by Armenia.
And surrounding Nagorno-Karabakh
are lands that
Armenia controls.
Then you’ve got all
the big neighbours.
Like Iran which
borders both.
Turkey — it’s long been
an ally of Azerbaijan.
And then there’s Russia.
It supplies weapons to both Armenia and Azerbaijan.
We’ll get into all the geopolitics later
but first here’s what Nagorno-Karabakh looks like.
It makes up 5% of
Azeri territory.
But almost twice that
much land around it
is controlled by
Armenian forces.
About 150,000
people live here.
It holds its own elections
and governs itself.
But right now
it’s a warzone.
Many people are living
in their basements
because of the shelling.
And local officials say half the people who live there
have been
forced to leave.
The thing about this region is that it’s been fought over
for a long time.
Iran had control in the mid-18th century.
Then the Russians
took over.
The British and the Ottomans were in there too.
But a key date in all
of this is 1920.
That’s when Armenia and Azerbaijan went to war
over Nagorno-Karabakh and Azerbaijan, backed by Russia
got control.
A year later it was promised
to the Armenians
but Stalin turned around and made sure Azerbaijan
held on to it.
By 1988 the Soviet Union
was crumbling.
And the Armenians in Nagorno-Karabakh
took advantage of
the power vacuum
and voted to
join Armenia.
So when the Soviet Union finally fell apart in 1991
so did whatever was left of peace in the South Caucasus.
1992 was when the fighting really intensified
right after Armenians in Nagorno-Karabakh
declared independence.
Both sides accuse each
other of atrocities.
Tens of thousands of local Azeris and Armenians
were killed
A million people had
to leave their homes.
In the end the Armenians pushed Azerbaijan’s forces
out of Nagorno-Karabakh, seized territories around it
and it all finally ended
in a ceasefire in 1994.
That ceasefire
has been ignored
by both Armenia and Azerbaijan over the years.
And the sense of injustice over what happened in that war
the killings and mass displacement
hasn’t gone away.
And now both sides are tapping into that anger.
It’s full-scale war
all over again:
trenches
tanks
air attacks.
Azeri forces have been attacking Nagorno-Karabakh’s
main city Stepanakert.
Armenian men there have been signing up to fight back.
Exact numbers are next to impossible to come by
but soldiers and civilians on both sides have been killed.
Armenian forces have been attacking Azerbaijan too.
The border city of Ganja has been among the hardest hit.
So how and why did the fighting start up again?
The answer depends entirely on who you ask.
Armenia says Azerbaijan attacked first.
Azerbaijan says it acted
in self-defence.
What’s clear is that it’s not exactly an even fight.
Our colleagues at AJ Labs put together these infographics
to show just how much
more Azerbaijan spends
on its military, how many more soldiers it has
and how much
more artillery.
And the Azeris have been showing it off.
This is an actual music video released by the Azeri military.
The Armenians are rallying their people too.
But what’s making this particular fight different
from all the other
skirmishes is that
other countries are getting involved in a big way.
Part of Turkey’s connection to Azerbaijan is cultural.
The Azeris are a Turkic-speaking people.
It’s got the Armenians in Nagorno-Karabakh
looking for outside help too.
So how involved is Turkey in the actual fighting?
Well that’s difficult
to pin down.
Azerbaijan’s using military drones supplied by
Turkey and Israel.
And Turkey’s accused of recruiting Syrian fighters
to help against the
Armenians
which Turkey and
Azerbaijan flatly deny.
So what’s in it for Turkey
and Azerbaijan?
Beyond trying to get back what they see as Azeri land?
Well something to consider
is that this region
is rich in oil and gas.
Pipelines snake across
the region.
Oil and gas make up 90% of Azerbaijan’s exports.
And as for Turkey, Azerbaijan is now its biggest supplier
of natural gas.
So understandably any instability here
is bad for business
all around.
Azerbaijan accuses the Armenians of attacking
a major oil pipeline which Armenia denies.
One thing’s for sure.
Azerbaijan’s oil-and-gas has come in handy.
The other reason Turkey and Azerbaijan say they support
the offensive on Nagorno-Karabakh
is that they think the dispute has been allowed to fester.
And now is the time to resolve it once and for all.
It’s true that over the
years there’ve been
lots of negotiations.
The UN’s put out a
bunch of resolutions
to stop the fighting.
And all the big international organisations
have weighed in too, including something called
the Minsk Group led by Russia, France and the United States.
They came close to getting the two sides to agree on
a peace plan in 2007
but it fell apart.
But like all the other
plans so far
they’ve failed to overcome that deep mistrust.
Both sides accuse each other of terrible things:
massacres, ethnic cleansing and taking land
so it’s hard to make peace.
Ceasefires only
pause the fighting
they don’t resolve it — and history has shown that.